hi there Steve Kaufman here my 90 days
of Ukrainian is officially over
I've spent basically three months and
when I started I watched this program
from Ukraine called Shuster live and I
understood what the Russian speakers
were saying and I didn't understand what
the Ukrainian speakers were saying
although I felt that I should because it
sounds it similar now three months later
I understand what the Ukrainian speakers
are saying I can understand them I can
read it I have you know my vocabulary I
don't know what my link statistics are
but you know I've acquired a significant
vocabulary in Ukrainian much of that
vocabulary is similar to Russian or
possibly similar to check apparently
quite similar to polish but I haven't
learned polish but it's also a matter of
getting used to the sounds getting used
to the flow of the language and so I've
achieved that and you know the other day
David mentor a who's one of our
community of online sort of polyglots
posted a question on his Facebook page
do you spend more time learning the
language or using the language and it
struck me that in my case using the
language learning the language it's the
same it's the same activity I don't
think that speaking is sort of a
stronger or a better use of the language
than listening and reading if I'm
listening and reading to things of
interest to me I'm using the language
and as I'm listening and reading I'm
learning the language so using learning
I mean if I'm speaking I'm also using
and learning so short of studying you
know declension tables or grammar rules
which would be purely learning
activities and which I don't do a lot of
most of my learning activity is using
activity and and it gets back to a theme
that I often develop here I think
there's far too much emphasis placed on
speaking as the goal of instruction from
the beginning as the only valid way to
you
use the language any of the languages
that I don't use very often if I were to
spend a week or two intensively
listening and reading and especially on
link with the words highlighted in
yellow and saving some new words and so
forth I'd be right up to speed and so
the idea that if you you know use it or
lose it so if you don't speak the
language you'll forget the language I
think your language skills will decline
a bit if you're not listening or reading
but you don't have to actually go and
speak the language in order to revive
your level in the language and this is
very important because many people
myself certainly who study languages
don't live in a place where they can
speak all the time and it's not obvious
that I'm gonna that I want to spend like
people offer me or come and talk to me
in Portuguese or talk to me in Russian
on the Internet yeah I got lots of
things that I'm doing I'm done it might
be interesting it might often I'm a bit
disappointed so I don't really engage in
those random discussions with people I'm
happier in fact listening and reading
learning about stuff if I have the
opportunity to go to Ukraine one day it
won't take very long
based on my understanding of the
language with the vocabulary that I have
especially if i refresh before I go
there I'll be speaking within a couple
of days in other words I will activate
the language very quickly and this was
my experience with check and and with
Romanian so you know this idea of use it
or lose it yeah but use the language
includes listening and reading and so
now the question is having it achieved
what I wanted to achieve in Ukrainian
what am I gonna do now
I enjoy learning languages it's a
tremendous opportunity to to discover
like Ukraine meant nothing to me I had
no idea what Ukraine was all about and
now I have a picture of Ukraine another
country the cities the people the
differences between different regions
you know how they talk but they think to
some extent a little bit about their
history so now I probably will
continue listening to my Ukrainian
content and but I will then maybe either
I'll go and do some polish because we
have polish that link polishes is kind
of a you know there's a progression from
Russian to Ukrainian - probably
Belarusian and then polish so maybe I'll
do some polish again the emphasis on
listening and reading try to understand
what people there are saying how they
view the events in Ukraine for example
how they view situation in their
relations with Russia the European Union
and so forth and I'm quite convinced
that I can get right into as I did with
Ukrainian real genuine content very
quickly and at some point I might review
the grammar but it won't be so important
first to have to get words get used to
the sound of the language so that's one
possibility
at some point I've got to go and tackle
a totally unrelated new language Turkish
Arabic I'm not sure running a start into
that so Ukrainian mission accomplished
probably continue on that for a while
and then perhaps start doing a little
bit more of the more polish but
difficulty always is that when you're
totally wrapped up in one language like
when I was doing a Russian I couldn't
tear myself away to do check but I was
doing check
I couldn't tear myself away to do
carruth Korean I really enjoyed my
Korean in fact you know what I might
even go back and refresh my who knows
it's always difficult you know to move
to the new language but then once you
get into it you get totally absorbed
into it anyway ninety days of the
Ukrainian mission accomplished I'm
satisfied with what I achieved and thank
you for listening